وفي مقاطعه ذا بيروت جاء اتهمت السلطات
الاوكرانيه القوات الروسيه بقصف المقاطعه
خلال الساعات الماضيه اكثر من 90 مره
اضافت السلطات الاوكرانيه في المقاطعه ان
القصف الروسي تركز على اربع عشره منطقه
وبلده تقع على طول خط تماس مع القوات
الروسيه
واوضحت السلطات ان القصف استهدف بشكل
مباشر منازل ومحلات وشبكات بنيه تحتيه
في المقابل ذكرت مواقعها عسكريه روسيه ان
مقاطعه الروسيه تعرضت لقصف بقنابله
فسفوريه من الجانب الاوكراني
ونشر موقع
العسكري صورا لدخان يتصاعد من مناطق في
مقاطعه
واشار الموقع الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه
قصفت المقاطعه باستخدام راجمه الصواريخ
ولم تعلق سلطات الروسيه على الحادثه
الى كييف من جديد مع مراسل الجزيره حسان
مسعود حسان نرحب بك معنا ونسال اذا حول
هذا الهجوم الكبير الذي تعرضت له
نوعيه الاسلحه المستخدمه فيه وما طبعا
اسفر عن ذلك من خسائر
نعم محمد نحن الان في مكان جديد ايضا في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف تحديدا في حي
سلمان هذا الحي الذي يعتبر الاكثر تضررا
بفعل هذه الهجمه الصاروخيه التي توصف هنا
بالاكثر تعقيدا منذ بدايه الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا نظرا لانها اتت عبر سلسله من
الضربات والهجمات الصاروخيه من انواع
مختلفه ومن اتجاهات مختلفه في ذات الوقت
بطبيعه مختلفه نتحدث وفق الروايه الرسميه
الاوكرانيه التي اعلن عنها قائد القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه كذلك القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه عن 18 صاروخا اطلقت باتجاه
العاصمه الاوكرانيه
من طراز كنجال هذا الصاروخ الذي كانت تصفه
روسيا بانه الصاروخ الذي لا يقهر والذي
تصل سرعته الى اربع اضعاف سرعه الصوت اطلق
سته صواريخ او سته صواريخ من هذا النوع
باتجاه العاصمه الاوكرانيه وتقول القوات
الجويه ونحن ننقل هنا انها تمكنت من
اسقاطها جميعا كل هذه الصور التي اطلقت
باتجاه العاصمه الاوكرانيه تم اسقاطها وفق
الروايه الاوكرانيه يضاف الى ذلك ان عدد
ايضا اخر من الصواريخ وهو تسع صواريخ من
طراز كاليبر التي تطلق من السفن الحربيه
من البحر الاسود ايضا تم اسقاطها من قبل
الدفاعات الجويه وفق الروايه الاوكرانيه
بالاضافه الى صواريخ من طراز اس 400 وهذه
المره الاولى على الاقل وفق قمت بتغطيته
التي يتم فيها استخدام صاروخ من طراز او
من المنظومه الصواريخ اس 400 وليس اس 300
وهذه المنظومه هي مخصصه للدفاعات الجويه
لاسقاط الطائرات والصواريخ استخدمت اليوم
كارض ارض باتجاه العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف
بالاضافه ايضا الى صاروخ اسكندر الذي
يستخدم كثيرا ايضا وهو من انواع الصواريخ
الباليستيه وبعيده المدى كل هذه الانواع
المختلفه من الصواريخ بطبيعه مختلفه تقول
السلطه الاوكرانيه دفعه الجويه اسقطتها في
هذه الهجمه لكن هذه الهجمه ادت الى اضرار
كبيره
في الممتلكات واضرار ماديه حتى هذه اللحظه
ما يتحدث عنه الجانب الاوكراني هو ثلاث
اصابات فقط هنا في حي سلمانسكي لا نستطيع
ان نقترب من المكان الذي كان الاكثر تضررا
في هذا المكان وتتكتم السلطات الاوكرانيه
عليه تماما لكننا نستطيع ان نظهر لكم بعض
الاضرار الجانبيه في مثل هذا المكان على
سبيل المثال كما ستشاهدون
الزجاج هنا في هذا المكان تعرض للكسر في
عدد من الشقق في هذه المباني وبدا السكان
بالرحيل عن هذا المكان قبل ان نبدا هذا
البث كنا نشاهد السكان يرحلون من هنا نظرا
لاضرار قالوا انها حدثت ايضا في داخل هذه
المنازل وهذه الاضرار ناجمه عن الانفجارات
القويه محمد نحن نغطي الحرب الاوكرانيه
منذ اكثر من سنه ولم نشهد في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كييف مثل هذه الاصوات انفجارات
القويه للغايه التي كانت خلال الليله
الفائته بالاضافه الى حجم الدفاعات الجويه
حجم عدد الطلقات والرشاقات من الدفاعات
الجويه التي كانت تحاول صد هذه الضربات
الجويه الضربات الصاروخيه واعتراض
الصواريخ التي تطلق باتجاه العاصمه
الاوكرانيه هذه الضربات الصاروخيه اتت
ايضا قبل ان يتم مره اخرى استهداف العاصمه
الاوكرانيه
ايضا من طراز شاهد كما تقول السلطات
الاوكرانيه ايضا اعترضتها دفاعات الجويه
ثم مسيرات ايضا وطائرات استطلاع كما تقول
الدفاعات
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه كل هذه ايضا
ايضا هيئه خلال هذه الليله على دفعتين
الدفعه الاولى كانت عبر صفارات انذار
امتدت لمده ساعه ونصف ثم
لسفره انذار ايضا الى حوالي نصف قامت فيها
دفاعات الجويه باعتراض مسيرات انطلقت من
الجهه الشرقيه الجنوبيه للعاصمه
الاوكرانيه هذه الهجمه هي الهجمه الثامنه
من نوعها منذ بدايه شهر مايو كل يومين
تقريبا تشهد العاصمه الاوكرانيه هذه هذا
النوع من الهجمات المكثفه سواء كانت
بمسيارات
انتحاريه خلال الاسبوع الماضي تم اطلاق
اكثر من 36 مسيره انتحاريه من طراش شاهد
باتجاه العاصمه الاوكرانيه كياف تقول
القوات الاوكرانيه ايضا انها اعترضت كافه
هذه المسيرات في سماء العاصمه وادت كذلك
الى اضرار ماديه وبالممتلكات واصابه عدد
من الاشخاص يضاف الى ذلك ايضا ان العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف كانت قد تعرضت ايضا خلال
الايام الماضيه الى عدد من الهجمات وتقول
ايضا القوات الاوكرانيه انها استطاعت ان
تسقط وان تفشل هذه الهجمات لكنها تحذر من
ان هذه الهجمات يمكن ان تستنزف الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه